years of uncertainty bothered fans of
the bad-boy series regarding a sequel
however now it's finally official bad
boys part 3 will be filmed on the
occasion of the first day of shooting
Will Smith also released an image of
some bad boys scripts with the words
they want I'll keep you posted
little is known about the plot except
that the story is about a drug cartel
and that the two policemen McLaury and
Marcus Burnett are supposed to bustin
the mega scene heroic Hollywood even
claims to know that the drug cartel boss
has the order to assassinate Michael
Oren
if that's true the movie titled bad boys
for life would have a rather sad
aftertaste there will also be a surprise
behind the scenes as cult producer
Michael Bay will no longer be involved
in the third part instead the two
Belgians a DLL RB and Bilal Fowler will
take over his room the US release for
bad boys for life is on January 17 2020
all-clear is given to fans who expected
the third guardians of the galaxy part
in the near future and were disappointed
after the scandal around director James
Gunn who was excluded from the film
production after a dispute with Disney
on Twitter the work is set aside for the
time being it's more than understandable
that the fans reacted very sensitively
and even predicted an end to the
Guardians although there are no specific
details about the release date Marvel
boss Kevin Feige confirmed in an MTV
interview that guardians of the galaxy 3
was definitely not put on ice but is
still in production however fans of the
series still have to be patient as
Marvel is currently busy shooting black
widow and the Eternals last Sunday the
Golden Globes were awarded in Los
Angeles and so shortly before the Oscar
ceremony movie fans from all over the
world were looking forward to the prize
and the surprise - chosen by the jury
and the following we will give you a
small overview of the winners of the
ceremony
Freddie Mercury continues to ensure
worldwide success after his death since
Bohemian Rhapsody starring Robbie Mallik
as the queen lead singer wins the
probably most important Golden Globe in
the category Best Drama and thus over
shines its opponents black panther and a
star sport there has been a small
surprise in the category best comedy in
which Green Book was able to assert
itself against the favorite and wise
less unexpected was the award for the
Netflix production Roma s best foreign
language film which is still considered
as the frontrunner for the category best
film of the year at the Academy Awards
in February as expected the team of the
animated film spider-man a new universe
also received a golden statue and will
enter the Oscar ceremony with a lot of
tailwind according to the jury Glenn
Close from the wife and as expected
rami malek from Bohemian Rhapsody can
call themselves best actors to what
extent the Golden Globe will assure an
award at the much more important Oscar
ceremony will be shown live on
television on February 24th 2019 the
wedding has come to an end after long
back-and-forth
due to script optimizations we finally
know that the shooting star true the new
Batman movie will happen this year
already shortly after the release of The
Dark Knight Rises in 2012 there were
speculations about the possible Batman
solo movie also called the Batman by
fans the only thing that is certain is
that Ben Affleck who was supposed to
direct the DC blockbuster will be
neither working in front nor behind the
camera however what will please the fans
most is that according to several
reliable insider sources the shooting
will already start in November 2000 19
which means that the costings are now
fully in swing so hopefully some plot
details and the actors names will be
released in the next weeks or month for
now unfortunately we have no other
choice but to wait for more news about
the upcoming Batman solo boom
after Sony's black pastor venom brought
over 850 million u.s. dollars in that
box offices worldwide Sony more or less
surprisingly announced a second part a
few days ago part of venom 2 will be
again Tom Hardy Michelle Williams and
Woody Harrelson among others who were
already highly acclaimed in the first
part we don't know yet who will be
allowed to sit in the director's chair
further it is certain that ruben
fleischer has expressed great interest
but is probably still busy with his
other project Zombieland - it is also
unclear when venom 2 will be shown in
the cinemas but it seems almost certain
that we will see the antihero on screen
by the end of 2020 as Sony announced to
spider-man spin-offs for next year what
many fans are still very interested in
is whether or not the popular spider-man
will be seen in the venom movie however
even screenwriter Jeff Pinkner still
keeps us waiting
because only recently he announced that
spider-man could play a significant role
in the upcoming venom movie
[Music]